et et drieu godefridi docteur en
philosophie
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors évidemment
on s'interroge sur les intérêts
américains l affaire des sous-marins a
déjà démontré une volonté de peser face
à la chine en matière de coopération
multilatérale est ce que c'est cette
même ambition qui motive les états unis
à à paris
je pense que ce qui ce qui motive les
états unis à paris c'est essentiellement
de refaire dans la mesure du possible
une relation qualitative avec la france
puisque cette relation a été je dirais
considérablement endommagée à la page
sur le plan symbolique et sur le plan
économique avec la faire des sous marins
quant à savoir si ce forum en tant que
telle est donc la présence américaine
dans ce forum a une réelle portée sur la
gestion des affaires internationales et
a fortiori sur la paix mondiale on peut
se montrer beaucoup plus sceptique jeudi
est la france qui doit prendre
d'ailleurs la présidence de l'union
européenne en janvier prochain est-ce
que parmi les points de convergence il
faut aussi compter sur le soutien
américain à l'europe de la défense chara
emmanuel macron héros forcément de
l'otan
c'est à dire que la relation entre les
pays européens et les américains sur sur
le temps est une relation qui est elle
aussi endommagé depuis de longues
geniuses et pas simplement pendant le
mandat de monsieur troubler les
difficultés à remonter à avant le mandat
de monsieur preuves et se poursuivent
jusqu'à nos jours la vraie difficulté
principale étant l'échec de la grande
majorité des états européens aujourd'hui
en ce compris et à commencer par
l'allemagne a consacré un budget
suffisant au maintien et à fortiori au
développement d'une force militaire
qu'ils soient suffisantes c'est là
l'europe de la défense repose depuis des
années voire des dizaines d'années sur
une grande île ce n'est pas parce que
vous mettez des forces qui sont
insuffisantes voulez vous les voulez
rassembler que cela fait nécessairement
une force suffisante il y a un problème
de crédibilité européenne par rapport à
l'otan qui est d'abord et avant tout un
problème budgétaire
alors il ya d'autres enjeux lors de ce
forum deux ans de ce forum dans le
domaine numérique et la lutte contre la
cyber sécurité est ce que là aussi on
peut parler de réels points de
convergence à face à la domination des
grandes plateformes numériques et les
cyber-menaces également
le votre question est très intéressant
parce qu'elle pose véritablement
l'intérêt la question de l'intérêt de ce
type de forum est ce qu'on peut
sérieusement imaginer que lorsque vous
allez à la réunion d'un forum sur la
paix qui se saisit de questions aussi
vaste aussi multilatéral aussi complexe
est aussi fortement déterminé je dirais
par l'ordre américain peut-on réellement
imaginer ou concevoir l'idée que ce
forum permettra des avancées
substantielles sur de telles questions
j'utilisais le mot de scepticisme tout à
l'heure à c'est particulièrement le cas
sur des questions comme comme celle là
j'aurais également souligné qu'il y a au
programme de ce forum
d'autres questions telles que
l'intelligence artificielle où la
question des débris dans l'espace ça
vieillit d'expression en français en vue
deux français médiéval qui dit qui trop
embrasse mal étreint
alors justement sur la forme on voit ce
forum a beaucoup d'attraits
kamala harris sa présence à paris ce
n'est pas joe biden qui s'est déplacé
mais donc la vice-présidente américaine
qui jouit d'une aura internationale
d'une image positive emmanuel macron on
sait aussi qu'il aime
ce jeu de la forme mais sur le fond
réellement est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
les choses concrètes à l'issue de ce
forum mondial pour la paix si je partage
effectivement tout ce que vous venez de
dire y ont en particulier votre
scepticisme sur le fond je pense qu'il
est il est illusoire d'attendre autre
chose que les prolégomènes à la
possibilité d'un accord sur un certain
nombre de questions ponctuelles telles
que la gestion des débris dans l'espace
pour le reste la présence de madame
harris offre effectivement à ce forum
une portée médiatique il n'aurait
probablement pas ou si elle avait été
absente mais en même temps qui est
madame harris elle est la
vice-présidente des etats-unis elle est
aujourd'hui est jouée aujourd'hui aux
états unis de 28% d'opinions favorables
ce qui est probablement le plus mauvais
scores de l'histoire de ce pays depuis
depuis sa fondation donc c'est elle même
une personne qui n'est pas véritablement
jeudi en position de pouvoir ou de force
justement ça forum mondial pour la paix
il a été initié par emmanuel macron sous
le prisme finalement ma chronique on se
dit que le président français il a envie
de reprendre la main un petit peu aux
côtés des états unis après on en a parlé
de la faire des sous marins sans cette
question là qu'en pensez vous je pense
que encore une fois on ne peut que
quelques jours en accord avec ce que
vous avez dit à monsieur macron il au
delà nous marquons la france a été
totalement humiliés dans cette affaire
des sous marins maintenant la france
n'est pas en position de pouvoir tourner
le dos je dirais aux partenaires
américain et donc il faut faire contre
mauvaise fortune bon corps et on a
effectivement ici un monsieur macron
quittant passe comme probables cheva
kron de devenir une sorte de deux
leaders de fait de leader virtuel de
l'union européenne avec leur train de
madame merkel donc on a ici monsieur
mâcon qui se profilent comme il aime
effectivement à le faire comme une sorte
de leader naturel en europe et ce qu'il
parviendra à maintenir cette posture
c'est ce que l'avenir c'est ce que
l'avenir nous dira une dernière question
qui concerne la crise sanitaire et
la couverture vaccinale à mondiale est
ce que les états unis se sentent
véritablement concernés par cette
fracture vaccinale nord-sud on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de chefs d'état
africains présents à ce forum mondial
pour la pisse question intéressante
parce que les américains ont maintenant
repris il peut sur que affectionne
c'est-à-dire donneur de leçons mais en
même temps il faut se rendre compte que
pendant la première phase de cette
pandémie les américains ont pris une
règle les anglais ont fait part et qui
était très sain chaque vaccin a produit
sur le territoire américain sera
attribuée à un citoyen américain
maintenant qu'il y à une forte
couverture vaccinale aux états unis
alors oui les américains s'inquiètent de
la couverture et à juste titre
évidemment parce que c'est de l'intérêt
de chacun de la couverture vaccinale
mondial et veut toujours rapportés ce
type de préoccupations
actrice à la généalogie je dirais de
cette crise caractérisée dans sa
première phase par un très grand égoïsme
nationalisme américain dans le même
temps que l'europe s'est montrée depuis
le départ beaucoup plus généreuse
effectivement dans la possibilité donnée
à des vaccins fabriqués sur le
territoire européen d'être exportée
partout dans le monde merci beaucoup à
vous à drieu godefridi je rappelle que
vous êtes docteur en philosophie